[Music]
I'm now on automata once it was
straightforward we were born free and
shackled by self-serving Authority now
many from neuroscientists to social
theorists argue we were never free in
the first place I'm not constrained by
our genes manipulated by technology
there seems to be little space left for
individual autonomy should we conclude
that the very idea of freedom was a
mistake which once abandoned will enable
us to reframe human behavior and success
and create a more equal society or is
this madness the threat is not just our
personal lives but the values of
responsibility and opportunity on which
our culture was built which is a big
question and that's as much as you
Loosli hear from me to today however we
do have a terrific panel to discuss
these issues which are pretty important
and pretty central on my far right is
Paul Brooks Paul Brock is a clinical
neuropsychologist turned freelance
writer his latest book the darker the
night the brighter the stars covers
topics like fate briefness humanity from
a neuropsychological yet highly personal
perspective on my immediate right is
Hannah Dawson history or historian that
were ideas political philosopher and
author she's written extensively on
early moral philosophy power structures
and the normativity of nature now I have
no idea either on my immediate left is
Julian boo Genie Julian is academic
director of the Royal Institute of
philosophy and founder of the
philosophers magazine his book how the
world thinks was described by the
observer as there to fill the sapience
sized hole in your life and my father's
Hilary Lawson and without him just
wouldn't be here he's also a
post-postmodern of philosopher and
critic of philosophical realism who is
best known for his theory of closure the
question which each of my my speakers
going to have three minutes to think
about and talk about with you are do
jeans technology and society now leave
no space for individual freedom and it's
you firstborn
okay well I could at this look second of
a neuroscience neuro psychology clinical
neuropsychology in particular and in
case I dropped dead of a heart attack in
the next ten minutes or give you might
take in just a couple of lines do we
have free will
yes and no I'm uncomfortable with that
paradox well that's a contradiction and
the point I really want to get across I
think freewill is intimately intertwined
with the motion of the self we can't
understand free will doesn't have any
meaning at levels of analysis below talk
of the self or the person why is it
important why it's freewill importance
because really because every kind of
freedom political economic social person
or whatever rests on this very basic
assumption that we have free will that
we can take decisions we can choose the
course of our lives we take trivial
decisions every minute of the day we
take big decisions not quite so often
but we're taking decisions all the time
and that is the essence of being a
person I think so free will it's
fundamental to the sense of self so I
need we see I think we need to put the
question of freewill
squarely within that context I think
free will doesn't make any sense
lower levels of analysis like biology
your physiology certainly not physics at
that level
words like purpose and goals and aims
and decisions and choices choices don't
have any currency whatsoever however
there the coin of the realm at the level
at which we talk about ordinary things
people interacting with each other the
goals and plans that we have in our
daily lives
now I arrived to this point of view
partly through my work in clinical
neuropsychology and when I got into this
field
about thirty years ago we knew quite a
bit about how the brain does things like
memory and language and controls action
and so forth
we did not know very much about how all
that came together to produce a sense of
self an introspective sense of self and
it dawned on me that we could actually
begin to think about these things in a
neurological sort of way
are they also realized there were people
who have certain brain conditions who
completely lost their sense of free will
and therefore their sense of personhood
and I won't elaborate them but now we
can come back to that if it's helpful in
this this time free free will or the
sense of free will contribute to that
part of ourselves which gives us unity
there's another part which gives us
continuity over time but it's that sort
of unity point of consciousness the
decision taking entity so I'm prepared
to accept hard determinism it's neither
here or there to me I'm prepared to
accept a materialist view of the brain
every thought feeling in action depends
on brain systems brain functions and
also prepared and we get onto this later
maybe to accept that neuroscience has
some very strong challenges to the idea
of free will but it's only at the level
of conscious self of it really means
anything at all
so think I'll leave that there
thank you very much Paul Anna thank you
um so I think like I think I kind of
agree with a lot of what you said Paul I
mean it seems to me that the question
are human beings free or not is the
wrong question and a dangerous question
because if we ask ourselves about the
ways in which human beings all human
beings are caught in a deterministic
universe inevitably that folks is our
attention away from the really crucial
ways in which some human beings are more
free than others so philosophers have
long thought that just as a matter of
metaphysical reality we live in a
deterministic universe Thomas Hobbes in
the 17th century David Hume in the 8th
centuries thought that every action that
human beings perform comes about as a
result of a chain of cause and effect
that's just the world that's the
metaphysical reality about the world
that we live in when I am confronted
with a choice between a stick of celery
and a piece of chocolate however much I
think I might have wanted to choose the
celery in the in the end I choose the
chocolate you know I think as I'm going
out for an evening that I'm not gonna
drink and then I get someone hands me a
glass of wine I think all right and
there's this way in which my actions are
determined you know another was sort of
deeper kind of psychoanalytic way of
thinking about it would be that I used
to think a lot about freedom and the way
in which I was making choices but it
just turns out as a matter of fact that
I've ended up doing broadly the same job
as my mother so there's a kind of versus
deterministic a metaphysical reality but
what David Hume pointed out is that sure
the world is the universe is governed by
determinism but that has no bearing on
our phenomenological experience of the
world which is that of freedom we feel
as though we are free we we experience
freedom and it's that lived reality
which I think we need to concentrate on
partly because as Paul has suggested
without the belief in freedom we lose
all sense of responsibility so if it's
if it's not the case that I'm free not
to murder if I'm not free not to lie
then it would make no sense to blame me
for doing those things and the entirety
of society becomes unintelligible unless
we take it for granted that there is
such a thing as freedom and the
responsibility that goes alongside that
and secondly the reason why I think we
have to think about the freedom as it is
experienced is because we all know the
difference between a life that feels
free and a life that is impeded in
various ways we are sitting here in
Hampstead free to talk
freedom when there are people in this
country who are locked in rooms being
forced to have sex there is a there is a
very distinct there are many crucial
distinctions between the experience of
freedom and different people's lives and
it's that that sharp end if you like of
the lived experience of freedom or run
freedom that we need to take account of
a woman is unfree if she does not have
access to legal safe free abortion and
of course there the ambiguity of the
word free is very instructive because it
indicates the ways in which our freedom
as human beings is deeply dependent on
our economic circumstances so there are
very basic ways in which money gives you
freedom in some countries if you don't
actually have money you don't have the
freedom to live because you can't afford
health care so I think that we have to
take account we don't we don't wait you
know screw the metaphysics come and
let's focus on our lived reality which
is that we know the difference between a
free and a less free life and it's our
responsibility as free agents to try to
give people as much control over their
lives as possible thanks very much screw
the metaphysics t-shirts will be
available after this session I think
when when Hannah said that free or not
sin that binary choice is the wrong
question I that's why I completely agree
with I think that if we if there's any
capacity that human beings have which
deserves the name of free will it's not
something we either have or don't have
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit a I dot TV
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas